alarm im saarland in saarbrücken ist im
stadtteil klarenthal ein polizeibeamter
durch schüsse verletzt worden demnach
soll ein mann ein waffenbesitzer aus
einem fenster geschossen haben ja der
67-jährige sollte wohl kontrolliert
werden so heißt es die beamten rufen
derzeit die anwohner auf in ihren
häusern zu bleiben und sich von den
fenstern fern zu halten der bereich
weiträumig abgesperrt und auch das sek
ist vor ort wir schauen direkt an den
tatort zu unserem kollegen der stephan
mayer steffen wie sieht es aus konnte
der mann inzwischen festgenommen werden
wie es die aktuelle situation
also der aktuelle situation ist so wir
sind jetzt etwa 50 meter weiter vom
tatort weg gezogen
das spricht dafür dass die zwei wohl
einen zugriff plant wie hat man auch
hier mit ein paar anwohnern gesprochen
es soll sich bei dem täter um den
67-jährigen
anwalt michael handeln die informationen
sind noch nicht bestätigt aber was
nachbarn sagen er wäre ein
sympathischer zeitgenosse und
ist es wohl so dass nicht nur die waffen
kontrolliert werden sollten die er
besitzt es ist die rede von mehr als 20
waffen sondern sie sollten ihm
abgenommen werden da gibt es wohl eine
gerichtsentscheidung
und die wollte die waffen behörde der
stadt saarbrücken heute vollstrecken ja
als es dann zu der tragödie kam bei mir
ist der polizeisprecher freikarten berg
hasenberg was können sie denn uns zur
aktuellen situation sagen also aktuell
befinden uns hier in der bahnstraße in
klarenthal heute morgen sind
einsatzkräfte das landespolizeipräsidium
gemeinsam mit der waffen würde der stadt
saarbrücken zu dem anwesen des 67
jährigen gefahren um dort eine suchens
beschluss des verwaltungsgerichts zu
vollstrecken in dem kontext hatte der
mann das feuer auf einen der
einsatzkräfte eröffnet der wurde hierbei
verletzt er befindet sich derzeit im
krankenhaus aber zum glück außer
lebensgefahr wir haben vorhin als wir
auch hier gestanden haben mehrere
schüsse gehört waren die nur von dem
mutmaßlichen täter oder waren es
schusswechsel auch nein wir hatten gegen
halb elf einer erneuten schusswechsel
diesmal zwischen der polizei und den
herren wie der sachstand ist müssen wir
momentan noch klären was weiß man dann
über den täter
wurde gesagt er war oder ist anwalt was
können sie dann zu ihm sagen ist er
vorbestraft oder ähnliches darüber
liegen noch relativ wenig erkenntnisse
bei uns polizeilicher art vor das heißt
wir wissen es ein 67-jähriger mann hier
aus klarenthal der im legal besitz von
waffen war die anzahl mehr als 20 können
sie das bestätigen oder zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt kann ich das nicht bestätigen
dass muss nachher die prüfung ergeben
wir haben auch gesehen die sind nicht
nur kollegen aus dem saarland aktiv
sondern auch aus aus aus rheinland pfalz
wir müssen kurz etwas umziehen weil die
einsatzkräfte kommen
sondern auch verstärkungen aus
rheinland-pfalz angefordert worden also
wir haben jetzt auch noch zusätzliche
kräfte aus rheinland pfalz mit hier im
einsatz denn hintergrund ist einfach
dass wir für jede lage entwicklung
gewappnet sein wollen und
dementsprechend habe ich natürlich
genügend einsatzkräfte vorgehalten gibt
es dann kontakt telefonischen zudem zu
dem mann wie der kontakt momentan
besteht kann ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht sagen ich versuche natürlich über
alle kanäle mit dem mann kontakt
aufzunehmen die lage zu friedlichen
möglich zu lösen
ja also ihr markt hier ist der einsatz
noch voll im gange jetzt kommt auch
gerade noch die feuerwehr und löst
möglicherweise andere kollegen ab diese
nämlich alle schon ziemlich lange im
einsatz
seit halb 8 8 geht es
ist dieser einsatz hier am laufen
steffen und wir sehen auch im
hintergrund immer mehr anwohner die sich
auch auf den straßen versammeln und zu
schauen was dort vor ort passiert du
konntest auch mit einem augenzeugen
sprechen ja was sagen die menschen vor
ort haben die schüsse gehört
die schüsse haben ja alle gehört auch
also die ersten aber auch schon als die
zweite runde schusswechsel runde war
standen hier alle auf der straße es
hörte sich an als ob sie eisen platten
aufeinander fallen also das hat jeder
mitbekommen ja die anwohner sagen sie
kennen ihn und also eher komisch gewesen
eher unfreundlich gewesen
der vater war wo jäger gutes schießen
natürlich einige spekulation man hat
gerade eben im hintergrund ein schuss
gehört ich weiß nicht ob das mikro das
eingefahren eingefangen ja die haben es
gehört ja
also wir fühlen uns hier aber sicher
also ist es kein problem das ist etwa
hundert meter luftlinie von uns entfernt
also da keine sorge über über den man
weiß man nicht allzu viel nur außer dass
er jäger gewesen sein soll wo der ist
sonst hätte ja auch die waffen nicht und
anwalt gewesen sondern
gerade jetzt wieder schüsse bei dir im
hintergrund vielleicht kannst du uns
kurz mal mitnehmen die kamera
umschwenken bekommt man jetzt
irgendetwas sei weiteres außer diese
schüsse von diesem einsatz nein die
kassierte kamera schwenken würde gar
nichts bringe ich geh mal mit dem
kollegen ein paar meter weiter ihr
werdet das dann sehen das ist sehr
weiträumig abgesperrt also werden sich
an die erste schalter erinnern kann da
standen wir dort hinten wo jetzt das
feuerwehrauto steht also die polizei
geht auf nummer sicher und man nochmal
schüsse
und geht auf nummer sicher und sperrt
halt weiträumig ab das ist natürlich
auch verständlich das spricht jetzt ein
bisschen dafür dass wir diese schüsse
hören dass da tatsächlich jetzt ein
zugriff stattfindet gespräch dafür wie
gesagt also kurz bevor wir mit euch das
gespräch begonnen haben eine minute
vorher sind wir ungefähr umgezogen da
hieß es wir sollten weiter weg es ist
wohl die sicherheit dann von den
anwohnern und von uns hier an alle
gedacht worden
ja also es ist jede menge los also man
muss sagen wir haben versucht mal
durchzählen ungefähr würden wir sagen 80
polizeibeamte schwer bewaffnet sind hier
rein und raus gegangen mit schutzwesten
also sek ist unterwegs ich habe es
gerade gesagt nicht nur aus dem saarland
sondern auch aus rheinland-pfalz sind
spezialkräfte gekommen und ja die haben
auch sehr
alte gerät schafft mitgebracht 1 aus wie
ein riesen böller den hatten sie
reingetragen also der war bestimmt zwei
meter lang wieso eine dachlatte aber
draußen saß austria müller dann hatten
eine kleine
mini roboter einen fahrbaren hatten sie
dabei
demant als es darum ging dass da dann
vielleicht mit einer kamera dann gefilmt
wird in der nähe des hauses
sehr viel spezialwerkzeug auch unterwegs